projet en attendant la colère gronde
toujours chez des agriculteurs bretons
qui manifestent depuis mercredi
maintenant devant la préfecture des
côtes d'armor
hier soir ils se sont violemment opposés
aux forces de l'ordre et cet après midi
les éleveurs qui je vous le rappelle
réclament au gouvernement des aides
d'urgence pour sortir de la crise se
sont à nouveau rassemblés cette fois ci
en famille et dans le calme reportage
hélène peu de chez serge le nour un
appel au secours lancé cet après midi
par les familles d'agriculteurs point
d'orgue à quatre journée d'occupation du
centre ville les éleveurs sont venus
cette fois accompagnés de leurs femmes
et des enfants
royaumont et pousse des gens travaillent
tous les deux sur l'exploitation et puis
nos enfants
nos enfants et vivre de ce que vivent
nos détresses aussi tous les jours donc
pourquoi il participera pas pourquoi je
suis venu pour avoir de l'argent pour
pouvoir partir en vacances est parti
depuis trois ans sic ambiance familiale
rien à voir avec les démonstrations de
violences de la nuit dernière c'était
quelques heures plus tôt sur cette même
place ce midi responsables syndicaux et
préfets se sont retrouvés autour d'une
même table
la nomination d'un monsieur crise en
bretagne a été confirmée dès lundi il
sera à rennes avec deux missions définir
d'abord les mesures d'urgence qui
permettront d'évaluer financièrement les
difficultés des éleveurs et de leur
apporter des réponses par les jours qui
viennent ces aides directes doivent
permettre aux éleveurs de casser la
croûte dans un premier temps dans un
deuxième temps pour assainir le marché
il faudra certainement permettre aux
éleveurs d'examiner de près à plan de
désendettement
ça c'est pour travailler sur le long
terme ce soir les éleveurs ont fini par
lever le camp saint brieuc il laisse un
vaste chantier